la policía informó que alrededor de las
10 de la mañana un hombre de 54 años
chocó su vehículo contra la entrada de
la cancillería alemana en el centro de
berlín y como ustedes ya dijeron en la
persona de 54 años pudo ser detenida lo
que la policía aún no ha podido
determinar es en primer lugar si el
hecho fue premeditado es decir si la
persona chocó a propósito el vehículo
contra la puerta de la cancillería y
sobre todo si tiene alguna relación con
un hecho similar que ocurrió en 2014 hay
informes preliminares que sugieren que
el mismo vehículo y el mismo conductor
ya chocaron contra la cancillería en ese
hecho en 2014 lo importante también de
este hecho es que se da en un día
importante desde el punto de vista
político en alemania pues hoy la
canciller alemana y los 16 líderes
regionales van a determinar cuál va a
ser la política alemana en temas de
coronavirus en las próximas semanas es
decir cuáles políticas van a estar
vigentes en navidad y en año nuevo
esas son las noticias desde aquí todavía
es claro si el choque o no tiene alguna
relación con lo que puede suceder hoy en
temas políticos en alemania
tomás gracias por la información por
supuesto vamos a estar muy pendientes a
esta noticia en desarrollo en berlín
gracias